april 23 2013 cracks had started showing
in the walls of a building in bangladesh
called the rana plaza
the rana plaza was home to shops a bank
and clothing sweatshops
the whole building had been ordered to
evacuate and not return to work until
the repairs could be done but the
sweatshops didn't have time for that
instead they threatened workers they
told them they would withhold a month's
pay if they didn't return to work the
next day most of these workers were
women and kids who desperately needed
the money they couldn't afford losing a
month's salary so on april 24th 3 122
people returned to work in the building
a lot of the clothes being made by these
workers would end up in walmart and
primark the sweatshop owners knew the
risk but they forced the workers to go
anyways and just a few hours after the
sewing machine started up catastrophe
hits
at 9am on april 24 2013 rana plaza
collapses
an eight-story building collapsed today
killing at least 145 people during
morning rush hour it simply collapsed
it's estimated that more than 3 000
people mainly female garment workers
were inside when the building came down
the sound of crushed concrete and
falling walls could be heard all
throughout the city
people who felt the collapse said it
felt like an earthquake
after the collapse the search for
survivors and victims took almost three
weeks in the end over 2000 people were
injured and 1134 died
it was one of the most preventable
accidents of its kind in history but it
was definitely not the only one these
sorts of catastrophes happen regularly
in sweatshops those reports of managers
locking doors to stop workers from
getting out and even when building
owners know conditions are dangerous
they still force their workers to show
up
and all of this is fueled by something
called fast fashion
so you're a fast fashion brand like zara
h m and forever 21 and you make your
money by selling something that's always
in demand cheap trendy clothes a famous
tick tocker posts a viral video wearing
a bucket hat and two weeks later your
shelves are stuck with bucket hats of
every color two weeks later the bucket
hats are gone replaced with whatever she
wore on her trip to hawaii
unlike slow fashion from decades ago
people aren't buying high quality
clothes to wear for years at a time
anymore they're buying low quality
pieces that are made to be worn just a
few times than thrown outs so now the
name of the game is making clothes as
quickly and cheaply as possible to
capitalize on these trends so that every
time customers walk into your store
they're bombarded with low prices sales
and discounts on clothes that are in now
but will be out of fashion tomorrow
today the average piece of clothing in
america is worn just seven times before
it gets thrown out and one out of every
10 piece of clothing and fast fashion
stores don't even get bought they just
end up in landfills and the only way
these insanely low prices are possible
are with sweatshops of course with some
of the worst working conditions in the
world and here's how you can do it
yourself
[Music]
just like how new fashion trusts can be
spotted weeks before they actually hit
the stores business and investment
trends can be spotted long before they
pop off and if you're able to catch on
to these trends early you can make a lot
of money but this used to be a very
tricky process that is until trends came
along
with trends finding the next big thing
is ridiculously easy here's how it works
trends team of expert business analysts
vet thousands of business ideas and
sends the best ones straight to your
inbox every week long before they pop
off not only is that a great resource if
you're looking to start a new business
but it would save you months of research
testing and the feeling of regret that
you didn't start sooner and that's not
all trends also gives you access to an
ambitious community of over 15 000
people where you could find your next
co-founder or investor like this example
where trends uncover signals at the
indoor plant business was set to boom
one member took that report and launched
a d2c plan startup now rec received some
valuable advice from the trends
community and then started building 40
days later he raised 1.5 million dollars
in funding or craig who ran a brand
called nerdy nuts when he joined trends
he asked for honest feedback and got
roasted members repositioned his brand
and had him focused on d2c the results
he went from netting sixty thousand
dollars to one million dollars in
revenue just a year later so if you want
access to these vetted business ideas
and the community to make it happen go
to trends.co jtram with the link below
to get a seven day trial of trends for
just one dollar that's trends.comtran
with the link below thanks to trends for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
so let's say you're planning on filling
your store with the latest trendiest
cotton shirts from sourcing material to
sewing on labels you need to make sure
the people involved are working as fast
and for as little money as possible
here's the step-by-step guide to making
as much profit in as little time as
possible
step number one copy the design of the
most popular con shirt you can find at
the moment don't waste time or money on
designers just rip off another design
change it up a bit and boom you are now
a fashion designer it's the reason why
the clothes in every fast fashion store
look almost exactly the same
[Music]
step number two sourcing your materials
now this is where things start to get
fun you see you could buy responsibly
source cotton from a reputable farm but
that's just so expensive these farms are
paying their employees a living wage
giving them time off benefits insurance
and you're the one that's expected to
pay for it by buying their cotton no
thanks instead sorcerer khan from a
country like uzbekistan in uzbekistan
the government owns most of the land and
farmers have to lease it in order to
plant crops like cotton but because the
government owns all the land they've
created a monopoly where each cotton
farmer has to meet insane cotton
production quotas and sell their cotton
at a specified low price or risk being
left without any sort of work or income
at all in most cases the price set by
the government is even lower than the
production costs their solution slave
labor
every harvest thousands of civilians
including doctors teachers and children
are forced to work on cotton farms to
help reach production goals these
workers aren't paid they have to live in
camps or buildings without running water
and if they refuse to work they may find
themselves publicly humiliated punished
or fired from their regular jobs and
even though most major fashion brands
have signed agreements to not buy from
uzbekistan companies like forever 21 and
urban outfitters still sometimes get
caught using the country's cotton if you
don't want to go with uzbekistan maybe
sorcerer khan from xinjiang xinjiang is
the westernmost region of china it's
known for its energy reserves its giant
cotton industry producing one-fifth of
the world's con supply and its
concentration camps for uyghurs
after these camps were set up these same
prisoners were brought onto confronts
and factories to be used as forced labor
what all of this means is that you get
some very cheap con but beware since
xinjiang's camps are in the mainstream
now any association with them can lead
to your brand getting boycotted or
cancelled
but since this supplies one-fifth of the
world's cotton supply and that china is
so opaque you have some plausible
deniability the supply chain is so
complex i didn't know we were using
slave labor
with such low prices for cotton
harvested using slave labor and so for
dirt cheap you're ready for the next
step in production making the actual
clothes
[Music]
step number three the sweatshop once
you've bought enough con for your
trending cotton shirts it's time to turn
the raw cotton into the shirts and this
is where it gets interesting because you
may have a factory in a country like
bangladesh or india but that is not
where the real work gets done you see
turning rock con into cotton clothes is
a labor intensive process which makes it
very expensive so instead of directly
employing people to get the job done you
outsource your production to local
sweatshops this again gives you a little
plausible deniability in case anyone
ever finds out the working conditions
your clothes are made in you never knew
things were that bad you were just
outsourcing the jobs to benefit the
country's economy so you send the
rockcon to sweatshops where managers
agreed to create clothing for dirt cheap
at turnaround times that no one in
america could ever dream of these people
are producing up to 20 shirts an hour
while being paid as little as 3 cents a
piece that is 60 cents an hour then you
take that same shirt and sell it for 25
in your store and the people who produce
the clothes they're mostly women and
children who work over 12 hours a day
170 million children are spending their
days working in some of the worst
conditions on the planets they're
verbally abused not allowed to take
breaks forced to work even when they're
tired sick or injured all that for maybe
two to three dollars a day if they're
lucky and when people start feeling
guilty for buying clothes made in
bangladesh or india or china well you
hit them with the best trick in the book
a nice old reassuring made in the usa
label
whenever someone buys clothes that are
made in the usa they assume it's
ethically sourced and manufactured i
mean there are strict laws in place
regulating the clothing industry and if
you're buying something made in america
you can do it with a clear conscience
right well that's what you want them to
think you see the truth is there are
lots of lupus when it comes to using a
mate in the usa label one great loophole
to exploit is manufacturing your clothes
on the pacific island of saipan which is
technically a u.s territory even though
it's part of the u.s saipan has its own
immigration laws and industrial
regulations every year thousands of
people arrive on the island promising
that they'll be able to get jobs in
america if they follow a complex
immigration process but the reality is
once they arrive they have to pay off up
to seven thousand dollars in fees most
of these people don't have anywhere near
that amounts so they work in sweatshops
in saipan producing clothes that will
eventually have a mate in the usa label
zone onto it and boom your customers
have a clear conscience and you get to
keep your margins
even in mainland america's strictly
regulated clothing industry sweatshop
still managed to fly under the radar
even in places like los angeles where
millions of illegal immigrants work to
produce clothing for cheaper than any
legal factory and when they're being
abused are forced to work well they
can't go anywhere because they could get
deported now that you have your
sweatshop up and running it's time to
hook in customers
[Music]
people naturally want to be like their
idols so get the biggest influencers on
tiktok youtube instagram and facebook to
agree to do brand deals with you send
them tons of stuff for free for them to
promote have them create videos with
titles like 400 shopping haul constantly
instill the idea that clothing is
disposable that cheap is good if their
favorite tick tocker is wearing your
clothes you must be a good company to
buy from make them believe that they can
throw their clothes out with every new
fashion trend or better yet that they
can just donate their old stuff to be a
good person if only they knew that 90 of
donated clothes end up in landfills too
make people believe that consumerism is
benefiting society that your supply
chain is creating jobs and making it
easier for americans to buy trendy
clothes the more people care about
looking trendy and fashionable the less
likely they'll care about things like
what's right once you achieve that
you're on your way to limitless riches
so let's say you followed every step in
this guide to the tea but like many
other brands before you you find
yourself caught in a sweatshop scandal
the best way to maintain your reputation
keep your customers conscious clean and
keep the money flowing into your coffers
is to pretend that you care
[Music]
immediately fire the sweatshop and
factory responsible for the scandal and
then send out your spokespeople to tell
everyone how shocked and horrified you
are donate to a charity that helps out
these workers and maybe even appear on
tv yourself licking the struts announce
that you are committed to change show
the world how you fire the factory
responsible for the scandal tell
everyone you're going to be sending
inspectors to every single factory to
make sure work conditions are up to code
and stick to your word fire the
scandalized factory but hire another one
immediately after this is even your
chance to shop around and find a cheaper
sweatshop than before and all those
inspectors are sending out they're just
for show you know that factory manager
just regularly force their workers to
lie to inspectors so as long as they're
telling them what they want to hear it
will be business as usual you can even
slap on labels that say sustainable con
onto your clothes that way consumers are
less likely to ask questions and more
likely to spend their salaries on
clothes that they're only gonna wear a
handful of times
[Music]
do i buy clothes from these fast fashion
brands yes but i actually have very
little clothes and the clothes i do have
i keep for a really long time i want to
bring this up because i'm definitely not
a saint myself and i don't like
pretending that i am it's been a while
since i've been on camera because it's
been super super busy but yeah if you're
new here this is the number one channel
for documentaries on money power and
crime so subscribe and if you want
documentaries that are too controversial
to post publicly you can click that join
button below and you will get instant
access to business documentaries going
over things that they will never teach
you in business school we have one of
monsanto mk ultra and the next one
coming out very soon is on everyone's
favorite private island owner efree
jeffstein so click that join button
below it's way cheaper than any like
education you'll ever get and there's a
refund policy too if you don't like it
email me and i will personally refund
you the money that's gonna wrap it up
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you